si una persona se desgarra el tendón de
aquiles el médico puede recomendar un
procedimiento quirúrgico para reparar el
tendón el tendón de aquiles es una banda
gruesa de tejido que conecta los dos
músculos en la parte posterior de la
pierna inferior sóleo
y gastro comió
al hueso en el talón del pie llamado el
calcáneo
es el tendón del cuerpo más grande y
fuerte
permite que el pie apunte hacia abajo
este movimiento es necesario para hacer
presión en el suelo para caminar saltar
correr o pararse sobre los dedos de los
pies el tendón de aquiles es uno de los
tendones más comúnmente lesionados en el
cuerpo los movimientos repentinos y
forzados hacia abajo o hacia arriba del
pie pueden desgarrar o romper el tendón
esta es una lección común entre los
adultos que practican deportes que
implican correr saltar y cambios bruscos
de dirección como el fútbol el
baloncesto y el tenis otros factores de
riesgo para un desgarro del tendón de
aquiles es el envejecimiento el consumo
de determinados antibióticos las
inyecciones de esteroides en el tendón
ser varón
un mayor índice de masa corporal fumar
una enfermedad vascular periférica
y la diabetes
una ruptura del tendón de aquiles puede
ser parcial o completa un desgarro
parcial significa que el tendón aún está
conectado un desgarro completo significa
que el tendón se rompe en dos partes los
procedimientos quirúrgicos para volver a
conectar los dos extremos del tendón de
aquiles se pueden realizar en una de
tres maneras abierta mini abierta o
percutánea
durante una reparación abierta el médico
hace una incisión en la parte posterior
de la pierna inferior la piel se abrirá
para que el médico pueda ver el tendón
desgarrado
el cirujano unirá ambos extremos
cosiendo los con puntos de sutura
a veces se usa un poco de tejido del
gastro premio
este tejido se doblará y se cocerá en la
parte superior del tendón para que sea
más fuerte
otras veces en cambio se usa un injerto
de tejido de un donante
luego la incisión se cerrará con suturas
o grapas durante un procedimiento de
reparación mini abierta se realiza una
incisión más pequeña sobre el tendón de
aquiles desgarrado se abre la piel para
exponer los extremos del tendón
desgarrado
se inserta una herramienta especial en
la zona
esta herramienta tiene varios orificios
pequeños para mostrarle al cirujano con
precisión dónde colocar los puntos de
sutura los puntos de sutura pasan a
través de cada orificio en la piel y a
través del tendón
se quita la herramienta que tira de la
sutura bajo la piel por lo que solo el
tendón permanece unido a la sutura
luego se voltea hacia abajo y se repiten
los pasos
el cirujano unirá los puntos de sutura
en la parte superior e inferior de cada
lado para así volver a conectar el
tendón
luego la incisión se cerrará con suturas
o grapas
durante una reparación percutánea el
cirujano hace incisiones quirúrgicas más
pequeñas se pueden hacer entre 3 y 6
incisiones pero depende del cirujano
los puntos de sutura pasan a través de
cada orificio y cada extremo del tendón
desgarrado
los puntos de sutura se jalan juntos
para volver a conectar el tendón
las incisiones se cierran con puntos de
sutura